hello Craig we're glad you're here
stand-up special homecoming king
received a Peabody Award in it he shared
his experience as a first generation
Indian American his new weekly series on
Netflix it's called Patriot Act with
Hasan Minhaj he explores complex issues
like affirmative action through comedy
and storytelling Minaj is also the
executive producer of the series good
morning there is nothing dumb about you
it's on welcome to the table no I bared
my soul on that I tell my SAT score so
it oh yeah people get very judgy what is
it I'm not gonna reveal it you can watch
it this Sunday by now yeah but it really
divided the audience really oh yeah what
is why well cuz some people were like
wow that's really good you gave it the
good college try and then other people
like you are an idiot but this is the
thing you call it Patriot Act but yet
it's not really about politics but you
want to start with affirmative action is
there comedy and affirmative action
where is it well I think if you talk
about yourself and you put yourself in
the narrative and like I talked about
being in college prep classes and sort
of the anguish you go through yes well
your parents are telling you and all the
pressure you have to go through will I
get in will I not get in but to me it's
a bigger discussion on meritocracy who
gets what and why and and I wanted to
pick topics that have to do with the
news but then tap into sort of a larger
sort of narrative that's happening in
the country that's timeless do you
believe in a meritocracy yeah well I
mean in the green room there the photo
of the Dalai Lama is this big and the
photo djt is this big the world of
meritocracy do things work for him that
yeah right
okay very good is there a meritocracy in
comedy I think like anything yes and no
there are certain systems in place that
benefit certain parties and there's also
things that are within your control that
you can do to become the best meaning
you can be because a lot of time in
comedy it comes out of underrepresented
groups sure who have this great kind of
wonderful sideways look on American life
and all of its pretensions and yeah in
fact it's sometimes a great place yeah I
mean I you were one of the
underrepresented that's the very
long-winded way to say minorities are
good at comedy but I agree well I agree
I agree that great comedy comes from
sort of pressure or sometimes feeling
like an outsider or how do I get through
this situation and a lot of times
there's humor in that and so I think I
didn't realize until later in life that
was my x-men superpower growing up you
want to just fit in and then when you
get older as a comedian you're like oh I
have the best tape because it's the most
happy but how do you how do your parents
feel about this taking this job they
really were hoping that I was going to
go to law school I remember I remember I
had this interview I did this interview
with Preet Bharara and they were like
wow you could have been him I know that
tell Preet this all the time like oh so
now you have a podcast you have you're
basically a comedian but you wanted
comedy you used to sneak out of the
house I've read yes because you wanted
comedy so badly yes you didn't want your
parents to know correct I would sneak
out no what do they think about you now
though the best thing pretty good son I
remember I like I remember looking at my
mom and dad at the White House
Correspondents Dinner and they were like
in the audience my mom was like Anna
sorry my dad was sitting there and I'm
like this is pretty cool right that I'm
making fun a Wolf Blitzer in front of
Wolf Blitzer yes not as a comedian yes
you snuck out of the house to do what we
do stand-up comedy yeah okay yeah and
then once at one time I came back and my
dad thought I was he was just like I was
just hoping you were doing drugs
[Laughter]
doesn't have a show less are you feeling
pressure do you feel I gotta be good I
gotta be good are you feeling I'm just
gonna be me and see how it goes
I just want to take swings yeah really
just you know share stories that I think
haven't been heard before mm-hmm and
sort of there's been a lot of stuff that
doesn't exist and you know you know the
way covering news is in this business
there's only certain stories that make
the front page right yeah and I think
there's a lot of stuff that's on that
front page that you know aren't attached
to tweets and it sort of that sort of
nonsense I won't have a bigger
conversation about bigger issues and
just take swings and what's Nicki Minaj
like at Thanksgiving dinner she's great
good wonderful yeah congratulations me I
just want to know your SAT score by
other side Patriot Act with Assad Minaj
premieres this Sunday on Netflix